they are extremely sweet of course and
on a good day very rewarding but let's
be clear about some other things that
are child centered societies never dare
to mention but should because the
silence stops us from understanding what
the business of having children is
really all about there's not very much
honest intergenerational transfer of
information here for the same reason
there isn't around the great dark truths
of loved with sight unashamed of our own
difficulties we shouldn't the job of
culture is to reveal friends never tell
you but everyone privately ends up
thinking so here a some of the big
secrets having children destroys your
relationship as a romantic sexual
concern people say you get closer over
the kids but this isn't the emotional
let alone sexual intimacy we'd want it's
more like the team spirit
you'd get between colleagues in a busy
kindergarten it's almost a biological
law kids will kill the relationship that
produced them we've bought into the idea
that all the problems people might have
from our childhoods come down to the
fact that their parents were mean on
neglectful be nice to your kids a
psychologist tell us and all will be
well but that's turned out to be
prepared leading as a parent you will
always have to put an end to a lot of
the fun
it starts with computers and gets worse
from there for the sake of protecting
your kids and you'll be hated profoundly
as a result indeed the more you love
them the more you're going to act in
their long-term interests and the more
hated you'll be at points unlike all
those fun-loving parents whose lack of
care buy some short term votes the more
you love your child and make them feel
safe the more they'll use you as a punch
bag when things go wrong in their lives
all those assurances I'll always be on
your side will pay off beautifully they
will encourage your child to direct
their every frustration and
disappointment on to the loving adult
whose signal that they can and will take
it the dream is that you'll be able to
pass on insights to your children let's
say around money or career or love
insights that you accumulated through
painful experience
and thereby you'll save them time but
sadly the human race is very committed
to re-exploring every dumb error in
every new generation you can't spare
people time modern parents want to make
things so nice for their kids but we
know from our own experience that we
have a key moments grown-up only through
things that had a painful sight of them
we desperately want our children to grow
mature but without going through awful
things they can't kids we'll need to
separate themselves from you it's a
biological imperative you can't live a
home forever but unfortunately that urge
for separation has a habit of expressing
itself very meanly in the period we call
adolescence it means finding parents
repeatedly ridiculous and silly and
trashing your life's goals and values
despite all the hard work your kids will
end up lioka you might have thought that
all the early lessons and care and love
will turn them into a version of Mozart
or Tolstoy
it won't there'll be very average people
who will have demanded way way above
average levels of commitment from you to
get them to adulthood many people who
learn they can't have children are
deeply unhappy don't worry have children
and will at times definitely regret it
don't have children and you will at
times also definitely regret it both
sides are just interestingly and
differently miserable but neither side
has very much to envy from the other
you